mr. bison ah sir thank you so so much
for taking the time to army with me yes
Dale I was a tournament looking this
year I've been crunching the numbers and
I'm you know it's okay but I'm a little
bit concerned with our travel budget um
you see here your idea was to have all
the fighters fight in their country of
origin yes
the primary fighter will host the
Challenger in his native land uh-huh
yeah so far it's a fun idea just frankly
sir it's uh it's not making much sense
just from my end of the table to say fly
right from Japan all the way to
California to fight ken just the very
next day to fly all the way back to
China to fight chun-li we're buying like
eight plane tickets for each fighter
business guys I am aware that you said
business class
hear me out what if and it's a big what
if we had the entire tournament in one
central location that the fighters all
take one flight to like say Atlanta
Atlanta Atlanta we need a diverse range
of finding locations no no no I know I
thought about that I don't don't knock
Atlanta you could have a peach tree
Grove you could have a back alley they
have a beautiful Hooters never sir
please listen to Risa we must fight in
Soviet factories aircraft carriers
temples full of elephants see see right
there that I'm glad you brought that up
temples full of elephants that casually
spectate the match and then celebrate at
the end I mean that's three months of
food lodging a very pricey trainer
we need the elephant's okay no Atlanta
keep the elephants I understand
next time Peter calls I'll just tell
them you have scary flame hand and I'm
sure they'll back off even though it
makes absolutely no sense
what oh one other thing sir that I'd
like to respectfully challenge is it
says every third match you'd like the
contestants to destroy a car it's a test
of strength
yeah that's it's good it is cool does it
have to be for budgetary reasons a fully
loaded mercedes s-class yes we must have
all the additional options GPS
navigation walnut trim steering wheels
DVD players for the kids
okay okay if you want to destroy a car
why not destroy a used Volvo which the
carnival stays thank you for hearing me
sir respectfully why are you even
throwing this tournament to take over
the world yeah because that makes sense
what up for one third the cost of this
enormous tournament you could buy a
James bond-style death ray pointed at
Washington DC and in an afternoon the
world would be yours into the dope the
fighters they do all the flips and they
shoot the fireballs it's so cool excuse
it's soaked I have you ever seen it when
to fire balls in each other I I have yes
I I do look at how do you again um sir I
have an Excel spreadsheet and sometimes
raise a red fire ball it's the coolest I
didn't think you'd get this bridge and
sometimes there's a double ko
whoo which is awesome and then everyone
claps and then I take over the world
em if you don't have this tournament in
a central location
I propose Atlanta in six weeks you will
be broke our profits do not justify our
losses I see fine we'll have it in
Atlanta come on Elena's not that bad
chin up I mean they have a date they
they they have a lot of street fighting
there i'll yet people probably won't
even notice it's going on and i really
that broke your divorce